police in Hong Kong have arrested
several activists in the pro-democracy
demonstrations that have roiled the
territory over the last three months one
of them is the well-known face of the
movement Joshua Wong
authorities say Wong and others are
being investigated for their role in an
unauthorized protest in June when
protesters broke aided police
headquarters police also arrested Andy
Chan a founder of a band
pro-independence party Wang was one of
the student leaders of major
pro-democracy demonstrations in 2014 he
was released from prison in June after
serving a five-week sentence related to
those protests for more on this
developing story let's cross over to our
Asia correspondent Charlotte Chelse
until she's in Hong Kong Charlotte what
can you tell us about the circumstances
of Joshua Wong's arrest and the
justification for it well this has been
a big sweep of activists this morning
Terry what we know about Joshua Wong is
that apparently he was picked up in a in
a car this morning in the early hours
taken to this police station where I am
right now shortly afterwards
Agnes Chou who is also within the same
party as him was also picked up to now
what we're hearing is that they are
suspected of taking part in unauthorized
protests in June 21st which saw the
surrounding of the police station they
were also apparently accused of inciting
those protests now those two arrests
came a day after another prominent
activist was also detained apparently on
the way to Hong Kong International
Airport we're also hearing in the last
hour or so that a district councillor
has been arrested as well so this is the
most high-profile collection of arrests
that have taken part that has taken
place so far in the last 13 weeks let's
be clear though that these are among 900
arrests of protesters that have happened
in recent weeks so a major sweep as you
say police are cracking down how are the
people in Hong Kong reacting to these
there's a lot of anger on social media
at the moment Terry and what's got to be
pointed out is that protesters this
protest movement started against that
extradition bill which was later
suspended but it's since evolved into
something very different particularly a
lot of anger at the way police have been
handling these protests protesters say
that they've been extremely violent in
their crackdown on those activists
that's fueled this whole movement now
these arrests are likely to incite even
more anger among people on the streets
they feel that the reaction from
authorities has been extremely unjust
what about Joshua Wong's arrest in terms
of the movement as a whole that he's
been leading who's such a prominent
figure in that what does that mean for
the protest movement in Hong Kong
well Joshua Wong is a very prominent
figure internationally due to the key
role that he played in the 2014 umbrella
movement but let's be clear this
particular protest movement these
thirteen weeks have been leaderless
protests have been organizing different
protests largely on social media a lot
of different individuals springing up to
organize separate protests so Joshua
Wong hasn't had the same profile the
same role in these protests this time
around and for that reason a lot of
people are particularly angry but it's
also an explanation why these protests
are likely to go on because they don't
need a figurehead like Joshua Wong all
the other activists to continued charlie
thank you so much DW Charlotte gelsin
Pill there in Hong Kong